pour les catastrophes se multiplient
depuis le début du mois 58 morts dans
les inondations russie 700 victimes de
la mousson en asie
à l'opposé il a neigé dans les andes
alors faut-il y voir une somme de
phénomènes isolés ou un dérèglement
général du climat
les premiers éléments de réponse nicolas
lisez et marie emmanuelle guidé
l'amérique du sud - 20° un mètre de
neige en plein mois de juillet une vague
de froid inhabituelle parcours le pérou
et la bolivie
au moins 100 personnes sont mortes les
plages de la costa brava ce week-end en
espagne
l'image tout aussi insolite pour un mois
d'août des bulldozer déblaie des tonnes
de grêlons dans les rues de barcelone
au même moment des pluies torrentielles
ravagent la russie la chine et l'inde
sont aussi très durement touché plus de
700 morts des millions de sans abri deux
pays victimes à la fois des inondations
et de la sécheresse
on le voit c'est l'ensemble de la
planète qui est concerné par des
phénomènes exceptionnels
mais faut-il pour autant parler de
dérèglement climatique est toujours eu
par endroits des fortes inondations de
fortes tempêtes forte tempête de neige
donc ça ça a toujours existé qu'il faut
voir un peu plus aujourd'hui c'est est
ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui plus de
phénomènes exceptionnels que dans le
temps or pour l'instant les études qui
ont été faites ne met pas ça en évidence
par contre ce qu'ils nous disent des
experts en climatologie
c'est qu'avec le réchauffement de la
planète dans les décennies qui viennent
on risque d'avoir effectivement une
augmentation de ce type de phénomène
exceptionnel exemple l'effondrement de
la banquise dans l'antarctique
en mars dernier un bloc de 720 milliards
de tonnes se détache certainement sous
l'effet du réchauffement climatique
c'est maintenant un fait avéré la
température s'est élevée de près d'un
degré ces trente dernières années
un chiffre qui pourrait atteindre les 6
degrés à la fin du siècle
il faudra alors s'habituer à un
changement radical de climat